cet homme qui a brûlé un Coran à
Stockholm en Suède provoque la colère du
monde musulman je t'explique en fait ce
jeudi 20 juillet la police suédoise a
autorisé un mini rassemblement à
Stockholm l'organisateur un Irakien
réfugié en Suède depuis 2018 sous le nom
de salouan momika expliqué sur sa page
Facebook qu'il prévoyait de brûler un
exemplaire du Coran ainsi que le drapeau
irakien devant l'ambassade directe
finalement il a piétiné le Coran
renonçant à y mettre le feu et cette
autorisation de rassemblement à
provoquer la colère irakien qui ont pris
d'assaut et incendie et l'ambassade de
Suède à Bagdad suite à l'appel du leader
religieux chiite Moktada Sader de son
côté le ministère irakien des Affaires
étrangères a condamné l'incendie de
l'ambassade et réclamer l'ouverture
d'une enquête toutefois l'Irak a aussi
menacé de rompre ses relations
diplomatiques avec la Suède si un nouvel
auto a fait du Coran avait lieu il faut
savoir que sa loi de momika n'en est pas
sa première provocation le 28 juin il
avait déjà brûlé quelques pages d'un
exemplaire du Coran devant la plus
grande mosquée de Stockholm pendant la
journée de l'Aïd aladda cet événement
avait aussi été autorisé par la police
suédoise au nom de la liberté
d'expression mais cet acte avait soulevé
l'indignation le 29 juin en Iran des
dizaines de manifestants avaient
protesté devant l'ambassade de Suède à
Téhéran au Pakistan voisin aussi le 2
juillet des manifestants se sont
rassemblés à Karachi en brûlant des
drapeaux suédois et pareil en Irak ou
des partisans de Moktada Sader avait
déjà pris d'assaut l'ambassade à Bagdad
en signe de protestation ils avaient
scandé des slogans et brûler un drapeau
LGBT des portraits de salon de momika
avait aussi été piétiné et le
gouvernement irakien avait fermement
condamné cette autodafé et réclamer
l'extradition du réfugié irakien vers
l'Irak pour qu'il soit jugé